my live-in boyfriend and i broke up a
couple of months back and he was moving
out from our studio apartment next week
but the nationwide lockdown hindered his
plan so
i let him stay longer now i just hear
him talk to his current girlfriend all
day long
the same girl who he cheated on me with
[Music]
i quit my job two weeks before
quarantine happened to work for a
startup company
i worked there for three weeks and then
the company got shut down
i have no prospects for a future job two
kids and a debt of two hundred thousand
dollars
i've started sleeping for 12 hours i
have no motivation to even
get out of bed wow
i went into quarantine head-on
determined to complete everything and
get ahead
but i've been sitting in my house for
two weeks now and struggling to find
motivation to do anything at all
i watch all these youtube videos and
influencers that show how they are
staying on top of their game
every day i do the same thing sleep eat
go on my phone
wash repeat it's like an endless cycle
that is so hard to stop
i kind of feel this as like the weeks go
on
i've just been so sleepy lately um and
even though i just like
don't get a house like i don't do much
this whole situation is
like affecting us and like our mindset
and our bodies in ways that we
can't really it's not explicit you know
so yeah
i was doing well coping with my
addiction of alcohol but the quarantine
has made me a bigger addict than ever
before
i can't even imagine trying to quit
again
uh yeah i'm sure drug and alcohol
addiction is
is escalating in the quarantine
i know boredom and loneliness
are two reasons to to want to overdo it
with alcohol or drugs and
yeah i'm worried about this i think
everyone should be checking on their
friends and family to make sure that
the the boredom and loneliness isn't um
driving them down
a spiral towards any sort of uh
alcohol or drug abuse i tested positive
for covid19 a few days back
i have been living in my car during
quarantine because my parents are
susceptible to the disease
and i have a chance of passing it on to
them with no other family or friends
willing to take me in
no health insurance and with not enough
funds for a hotel
i have to isolate myself in my car and
live outside
i have been saving the little food i
have left
man it's hard because this person is
trying to
definitely like do the right thing like
this person
is aware that his or her parents could
get sick and this is like a really scary
disease
but living your card is not
fun um definitely like with not enough
like funds to like
support him or herself
[Music]
at the grocery store a little kid ran
towards his mom
pointed towards me and called me corona
his mother gave me dirty looks abandoned
her shopping cart and left the store
i'm asian american i wish i had ordered
groceries online
there's nothing worse than experiencing
racism like to your face
honestly i i want to say
i'm shocked but i'm really not because
i feel like my reaction to
all that's going on across the world
would be people come together and people
are trying to support one another
and just showing love
yeah i i really don't have any
patience for people
who
who partake in that mindset and
especially for people who
pass down that mindset to children i
think that's disgusting
i've been locked in the house with my
father and older sister for four weeks
now
we ended up spending so much quality
time that i've started having feelings
for my sister
mostly sexual feelings
wow i didn't expect to read that and i
think this person
because of this circumstance
needs to go on some quarantine dates
with other people
my son usually stays with me over the
weekends and with his mom over the
weekdays
a nationwide lockdown was announced on a
sunday so he had to stay with me for
longer
i wish i hadn't called him over that
weekend i don't like having him around
every day that's so sad
i regret not hugging my friends for a
second longer when i last saw them
before the outbreak i didn't think of it
we were just going on a two-week holiday
and i was going to see them soon
it's been eight weeks or so now this
experience has taught me
that you never know what's going to
happen tomorrow should tell the people
you love that you love them
as you never know what's going to happen
and when it'll be the last time you
spend together
yeah i was watching news and i there was
these predictions of how many people
were going to die
during this period and it really could
be more or less but
there was there is going to be a large
like human life toll and i remember
thinking it was so weird it was like
these deaths that they're anticipating
they're like empty spaces and then
people are gonna fill them up
and you don't know who it is yet i have
tried to like keep up calling with
friends and family but
it's definitely still different than
meeting a person
[Music]
you